great session it's very unusual I think
seeing two very different fields collide
and hopefully exchange or explode or
whatever will happen anyway so I'm going
to talk about what limits the efficiency
of selection and start from the amazing
observation that evolution has produced
an astonishing diversity of complicated
genomes which code for complicated
organisms and they're actually two
different issues here I think I'll
concentrate on the first one the
evolution of large complicated genomes
but then there's the further issue which
is also astonishing that such a small
amount of information a few you know
million base pairs at most can code for
a very very complicated organism in a
very compact way much more efficiently
prepare a set then computer scientists
have managed to code for complicated
computers or software so just to you
know get a concrete facts we bear in
mind that the size of the human genome 3
times 10 to the 9 base pairs maybe no
who will emit does stuff maybe a lot
ability just random you know a lot of it
is just the Redax of trans possible
elements and so on but at least 10 to
the 8 base pairs from could deal more is
maintained by selection and of course we
have not just the end you know we have a
lot of other organisms which also do
complicated things have complicated
genomes how do we explain this and I
should say that my talking ways I have
complimentary to those valiance talking
the whole session yesterday morning in
that I'll be focusing primarily on
explaining the story of the size of the
genome ok which at least has the merit
of being a number we can measure that we
know how big this number is I'll also
say something about perhaps the number
of functional traits which could be
maintained by selection and I actually
have no idea what this is it's a some
big number but you can each think how
many degrees of freedom you think you
have ok but neither of those numbers
neither the number of functional traits
nor the size of the genome is the same
as the measure of complexity byblos was
using yesterday which was the number of
environmental variables or numbers of
state variables of the cell which which
are used in a mapping
having some response his f of X where X
is the dimension has is a vector with
the dimension that measures complex
something else again
at any rate um I should also say that I
greatly enjoyed reading your book
recently and what motivated the
beginning of the book was this question
where I think he quite rightly said that
we initially biologists had failed to
answer the question of how long should
eeveelution take and indeed this is a
question that's been around a long time
it worried Darwin one of the most
serious objections to the theory of
evolution by natural selection or indeed
to the lion lien theories of geological
processes acting slowly over time was
simply that there were good physical
arguments in the end of the 19th century
that the earth was only a few million
years old and somehow Darwin thought
that just wasn't long enough and kind of
think that's right
maybe we did need four thousand million
years to get to where we are today but
it's you know we still don't have any
April right way of getting a number for
how long should it take to evolve a
certain complexity of organism and
that's a hard question I'm trying to
make in this talk various sort of back
of envelope calculations to get at that
issue now we have a very good
quantitative theory for the rates of
which particular changes have happened
if we look back in time we can say just
how these various things happened and
how long it should take and so on and so
forth so nice example Penney recently
published by Dmitri Petrov grew up in
Stanford on evolution of insecticide
resistance in Drosophila resistance to
all kind of phosphates depends on three
specific amino acid substitutions in the
active site which prevent you the
insecticide binding and those three
specific changes have evolved within you
know 15 years or so independently
several times and that seems you know
radio remarkably quick for something so
complex but actually it's not so
surprising when you do the calculations
given that a single mutation can give
some advantage a second one to further
advice your third one a further
advantage so these can build up
step-by-step and there are a lot of
flies out there so the total number of
mutations coming in per generation is
really quite large so actually the
timescale is fitting reasonably well
with what we know about me too
population size and so on and the same
could be said for evolution of
quantitative traits the pathway rather
well fed depends in large part on the
success of selection on plants and
animals increasing crop field steadily
year after year and the rates of those
increases we can predict from patterns
of genetic variance in the short term
and they're extremely rapid and there's
a nice survey from quite a lot back over
simply rates of change over different
time scales here of various
morphological traits measured in
Darwin's rather unfamiliar unit note
Darwin is one part per million years
okay and the basic pattern is simply
that if we look at and say recent
domestication and say going back to a
thousand years we see well the rapid
rates the morphological change if we
select our specially very intensely to
get even pasture changes but if we go
back over long-term records of let's say
marine sediments looking back in the
fossil record we see slower and slower
change and kind of this this pattern is
obvious and in a sense while the trivial
just because if these rapid rates change
has been sustained over a very long
period of time then the authors wouldn't
fit on the planet right so change has to
be slow when average local occurred
sometime this is simply saying that
change can be rapid but it fluctuates
and so in the long run things stay kind
of the same but this is simply saying
that rates of change are potentially
much faster than those we observe and so
I think just give a bit of history this
question of whether there's been time
for evolutionists faded into the
background because people realize that
you know there has been time we're not
struggling to explain the rates of
particular events but there's still I
think a serious issue about what what
actually limits the rate of evolution
overall not just asking about particular
changes but asking about the aggregate
all the changes that lead to the
evolution of of a lineage and I think
it's open question whether the rate of
evolution is limited by population
genetic factors mutation selection
population size whatever or by patterns
of environmental change that what
matters is
the way in which a sequence of
environments occurs and moves little
guides a population towards some novel
morphology okay so what I'll do in this
talk you just gives some very rough back
of envelope calculations trying to get
at overall rates people who spend
constraints on overall rates of
evolution and I work the second thing
original and really trying to give a
sort of very rapid overview of
population and quantitative genetics but
before doing that I should just say
something about the structure of these
two fields the population genetics deals
with the frequencies of different
genotypes and we can think of genotypes
roughly speaking as since it's a
computer science Institute a bit string
nortz one's a long line in principle we
need to track the frequency of every
possible combination of nought someones
every possible genotype that's an
enormously difficult problem but
fortunately with sexual reproduction as
that we heard in in previous talk we can
make the drastic simplification that the
frequency of a genotype is closely
approximated in most circumstances by
the product of the frequencies of each
individual variance at each individual
lockers and that turns out to be wrong
with good approximation for help
crossing sexual species and so we can
describe the population in terms of a
list of allele frequencies okay I'm kind
of waving away a lot of interesting
population genetics about the
correlations although so-called linkage
disequilibrium between sites but for the
purposes for this talk you know to be
hard enough to get anywhere as it is so
we'll just deal with the new frequencies
now quantitative genetics in contrast
deals with complex traits with
phenotypes with things like height
weight growth rates whatever and it
deals with them statistically without
using any information about the
underlying genetics because in dean
until recently we didn't have any
information like the underlying genetics
and so the framework is very
straightforward it's almost always a
good approximation to treat traits as
normally distributed it multiple trades
are multivariate normal if they're not
exactly normally distributed often a
scale transformation or threshold
whatever will allow us to get things
into this very straightforward
statistical framework and even further
than that we can make a very drastic
simplification and very often find that
what's called the infinitesimal model is
a good approximation for trait evolution
so we say that we have two parents the
offspring are normally distributed with
a mean of the average of the two parents
and with a variance which is essentially
fixed independent of selection that
variance within families may increase
due to mutation it may decrease due to
inbreeding but crucially it can be
approximated as being independent of the
process of selection and it's this
framework which actually lies behind
practical plant and animal breeding and
turns out to be an extremely good
approximation to the statistical
description of sets of traits and it can
be justified as being a limiting case of
a model in which we have very large
numbers of genes of small event and
those effects being additive and of
course then you start to get a little
bit worried about whether we are
actually the sum of effects of each base
pair with us that doesn't seem very
plausible think we heard yesterday about
you know actual models of
transcriptional regulation in salt which
are highly nonlinear highly complex and
I think the major open question is what
set of actual nonlinear models is also
consistent with the symphony testable
and of course you could derive the
impetus for modeling as a limiting case
provided in a sense there isn't too much
interaction too much non-linearity and
providing the nonlinearities not
directional not systematic yes so over
ten hundreds of generations exactly well
in a sense
a lot of the constraints I'll talk about
can be thought of as short timescale
constraints about rates of old
accumulation of information under
selection okay so just to illustrate the
success of the infinite test bullet and
know give an idea of the time scales I'm
talking about this is a neat survey or
the whole variety of certain experiments
were people a web ranting into something
rather obscure is famous mostly for the
invention of the inebriate er
okay and this was a major advance type
of advance in drosophila selection
experiments because before the people
have selected on traits they could count
by hand and so you know even if you had
the most dedicated PhD student they'll
be driven mad by doing such experiments
of you know more than a few you know
tens of generations with more than a few
hundred individuals in just yeah
physically counting the individuals was
it was a bottleneck so whoever
introduced various schemes for running
selection experts on a large scale and
the inebriate er was a neat device which
was a kind of distillation column in
which there's light at the top there was
an increasing concentration of ethanol
paper the Flies came in they flew
towards the light they fell over the
trunk and they were kind of distilled
off to the side and you could fraction
ink the fires according to their
resistance to alcohol friend hence the
immediate relative so he did various
experiments like this had a wind tunnel
where the Flies were trying to fly up
against the wind and so on and and it
was really very interesting because if
you select your bigger bigger
populations will have larger and larger
response typically you select on any
trait in any population you'll get a
pretty rapid response or some fraction
of a standard deviation reflecting some
substantial genetic component of
variability and that will continue but
in a small population the variation will
be exhausted in a larger population
you'll be able to go further before the
variations exhausted and there's a very
definite prediction from the
infinitesimal model which goes back to
Alan Robertson in 70s which says that in
the long run in a population size any
vectorizer any the total response will
be to any times the initial response in
the first generation to a population
size of 500 you'll be able to get a
response a thousand times that in the
first generation simply an issue of how
long it takes for variation to be
eliminated by random zone and there's
also a prediction for the response up to
50 generations and so this plot here is
a ratio of response up to 50 generations
relative to the first generation these
are the predictions from the impetus
model as a function of population size
where them without mutation doesn't make
very much difference for closable values
of mutation and these are the
observations which cover a whole range
of different experiments on mice and
maize and Drosophila and so on and it's
kind of you know remarkable to me that
these fit just below these predictions
response is a little bit less than you
might expect because selection is
eliminate from variation as well as
random drift but to a pretty good
approximation you know given the the
inaccuracies in all of these sort of
experiments and all these sums are
making this very simple in Finnish
testable model gave us a reasonable
prediction to the response to selection
over these times goes up here 50
generations well so it's actually pretty
easy to understanding so there's a
maximum limit here if the population
size able to be large then you just
carry on going right so this is just 50
right that's the upper limit here we
have this limit to any but this is a log
scale here right and therefore it curves
exponentially so it's just a function of
having a log scale on here no theory is
that if you go an infinitely far out
then the ultimate response is here to
any times the initial response that is
to any given that this is a log scale
and this is a linear scale so it looks
exponential because I have to change
this to a Linnaeus to a log scale okay
so that's to NAU here and this is 50 and
it's an interpolation between us that's
all okay so so we have this sort of nice
model for quantitative genetics which
seems to be locally accurate accurate in
the short time scale even though we know
that the mapping between traits and
genotype some arbitrary function traits
or an auditory function of feed genotype
that's very very complex but we can
still get someone okay so back to the
question I softly what limits the
efficiency of selection and this
question had been asked primarily by
using various kind of load arguments and
these go back to the 1930s I suppose
originally Jenny glowed being defined as
the loss of fitness relative to some
ideal value some maximal value and the
idea is that if we can show that various
of processes of selection lead to a loss
of average fitness then we can use the
fact that organisms have some maximum
reproductive rate to set up a load on
how much
election could be acting and kind of
results that one gets are really quite
nice without their independent of the
actual nature and strength of selection
results which in the first one I guess
from halt dein showing that the loss of
mean Fitness due to mutation due to
deleterious mutations across the whole
genome it's just of order total mutation
independent of selection and the way to
think about this is to see that every
bad mutation that comes in has to be
eliminated by a so called selective
death by failure to reproduce or survive
and hence rather generally we have this
mutation load was of the order total
mutation rate
result which was mentioned in previous
talk from halt dein so-called cost of
selection also called substitution load
saying that the total number of
selective deaths total lots of mean
Fitness per capita is aboard a log of 1
over the initial frequency of some
variant we could think of a single
variant which is being pulled up from
let's say 10 to minus 6 up to 1 and then
you have a border that's on factor in
front here but of order log 10 to the 6
is the total loss of being fittest
summed over the whole period in which
you're trying to get from low frequency
high frequency this is the loss relative
to some ideal situation in which instead
of using slow inefficient natural
selection which takes time
you suddenly fixed the best genotype
available for the circumstances and then
there's also somewhat less well known
sokol drift load introduced by mera note
in 1970 which also applies to both
polymorphisms and two quantitative
traits in both cases we think of the
loss of mean Fitness due to the fact
that in a finite population we have
fluctuations away from the equilibrium
value and that will generally lead to a
reduction in mean fitness of order 1
over 4 times population size ok so this
is also imposing a constraint on the
numbers of polymorphisms that could be
maintained at a particular frequency or
the number of traits which can be
maintained at a particular Optum
and all of these seemed to set some
fairly strong constraint on how much
selection can be going on and as was
mentioned before the substitution load
for example suggests that the rate of
substitution cannot be more than let's
say 1 in 30 or one in a hundred per
generation and indeed Kimura in this
rather nice paper I can't now as some
confusion was in 1960 or 61 anyway
around then he actually calculated that
the number of bits of information
accumulated that is the net
improbability measured like this
accumulated since the cambrian along the
vertebrate lineage was about 10 to the 8
which miraculously is about the size of
the functional genome and these load
arguments has played a very prominent
role in the 1970s in the argument
between Kim Yuna and others promoting
the neutral theory who argued that these
load documents put a strong cap on how
much selection could be going on and
said essentially that all this variation
that was being repealed all of these
substitutions being revealed in
comparisons between species most of this
had to be neutral they wasn't enough
selection to go round to explain these
in an inductive way and there was a very
strong counter argument which pointed
out that these constraints all become
much weaker when genes interact and it
essentially can be broken so there's
plenty of selection available and I
think the consensus now would be that a
remarkably large fraction of molecular
variation is affected by selection ok so
let's go through these arguments about
what happens when we have a gene
interaction and this sort of a gender I
have here is sort of maybe to try and
see if computer science could be some
use and this is some radical thought I
mean the sort of my you know very buff
caricature of population genetics will
be that it's very good at calculating
rates of particular processes under
particular Morton's if you tell me the
types of the population what their
relative fitness is are I can say what's
going to happen I mean it's just
bookkeeping there's nothing fancy there
but it's very difficult to get results
which are general in the sense that they
apply to any map between Fitness and
genotype or between trait and Geno
and of course we know that's a
complicated mapping and yet we're forced
to ride models like the infinitesimal
model in quantitative genetics which
kind of work somehow we didn't quite
know why they work and we really like to
have a better way a more systematic way
of understanding the way Britain works
when we have some arbitrary relationship
it's a very broad undefined relationship
between phenotype and genotype between
Fitness and unit so let's think about
mutation load which may be the simplest
thing to think about if we have any
sexual reproduction and if we suppose
that there's a best type which has some
Fitness at some number of offspring per
generation going back to yesterday I'm
just taking Fitness here to be a very
boring quantity the number of copies of
an individual or gene left per
generation so you need to screen time to
keep things simple so with asexual
reproduction we have this fifth
individual producing offspring but if we
have deleterious mutations perhaps most
of its offspring will be different will
have one or more deleterious mutations
and if we assume mutations are always
taking you down hill which is a good
approximation then only a small fraction
of offspring will have the same genome
and so the effective number of offspring
produced is its actual reproductive
output W times sorry there's a it's only
a - okay would have been worse it was a
square root of minus one anyway no it
was a mutation that's always deleterious
as we know yes okay so you basically
find that the actual fitness of the
fittest type times the probability of
producing an identical offspring which
if we see more possible distribution of
mutations total rate big u that is w
times e to the minus u that has to equal
the average fitness of the whole
population which in the long run will be
around one and so that's a very simple
argument tells you that the the ratio
no even survives for the first time
superposition and then I can move into
the other session yeah I get to say
what's wrong in a minute right yeah okay
full Sgt some name the correct audience
maybe you maybe are mostly on false
oculus okay so this is a very simple
argument which is based on asexual
reproduction on unidirectional mutation
and it says that you know regardless of
the details of how Fitness is determined
by the genotype Fitness is going to be
reduced by a quantity that depends on
the total rate and deleterious mutation
and that's a that looks bad for us I
mean if we apply to humans then we say
well we've got sexual reproduction but
this should still apply if we could make
the assumption that Fitness selects of
different mutations multiplied together
in that world a multiplicative effect
then this still applies and we have a
substantial loss of our fitness I mean
we we're now getting to know what the
total
downshifts mutation rate is although in
the first workshop of this session
there's a nice talk by multiple choice
key who actually showed that we didn't
know as much as we thought we did and
there was a big range in the estimates
but they seemed to be pretty high total
rate of mutation per diploid human
genome maybe 60 or so of course most of
those may be more less neutral but if we
look at those sections of genome which
seem to be conserved seem to be evolving
slower than neutrally we get a total
denturist mutation rate which is
worryingly hi we should have a
substantial loss of reproductive
capacity due to deleterious mutation of
course we do less potential load due to
genetic disease but these figures are
suggesting that maybe we're you know we
should be worse off than we actually are
okay so how do we get out of this well
it turns out that in a sexual population
the number of bad mutations can be
substantially less than predicted by
these simple nice documents if genes
interact in the right way and there's a
simple graphical way to see this suppose
we put the log of the mean Fitness
against the average number of
deleterious mutations in the population
the equilibrium is one between mutation
putting deleterious mutations in
selection eliminating them and selection
is given by the slope of the relation
between log mean Fitness and numbers of
deleterious mutations what matters is
the marginal effect on the increasing
the number of deleterious mutations by
one if the raishin ship is
multiplicative giving a straight line on
this log scale then we can use simple
geometry to see that the height here is
just equal to the total deleterious
mutation rate just from the fact that
the slope of this line is s and this
here is U over s so this is U geometry
and so in other words if we extrapolate
from the numbers of deleterious
mutations here and their marginal effect
in this population we predict that the
fittest individual should be incredibly
fit should be someone who's producing
you know 200 children per generation
that doesn't seem possible for humans
it's an interesting thought experiment
we could probably do this nowadays I
mean all you do is not the human se but
the you still flies let's say we just
put at each site the consensus allele
and that would normally be the fitter
allele okay if we have a simple mutation
searching model the question is just
what would that organism look like and
prediction is that if FX is
multiplicative it will be ridiculously
fit and the point is that if we have
this kind of pattern of negative
epistasis of downward curvature of
accelerating deleterious effects as we
get more and more bad mutations then you
can have a strong marginal effect but a
small cumulative effect if we take it
out to there so it's simply an issue of
extrapolation here importantly it's not
anything to do with patterns metastasis
within this population it's really about
what we're predicting about the perfect
organism is that an absurdly fit
organism so one way to look at the
failure of this kind of load argument is
to say that well we should only really
make arguments about relative fitness
about comparisons between actual
organisms we can actually see and
measure because at least at the moment
these without a lot of money we can't
construct this perfect tool
yeah I think it's probably a bit other
side lightness because there the
question is whether there are two
distinct issues or one thing which are
two sides of the same coin and I'm not
sure about that I mean so I mean the
point you're raising is that there may
well be a lot of variation in fitness
which is due to competition due to
sexual selection due to things that
aren't if you like concrete physical
constraints it's a matter of relative
competition between individuals in
population I think you know whether or
not that's important or whether it's an
issue of epistasis so I guess yeah I'll
agree with you actually yeah it's no
distinct issues but either way what we
should do is simply ask about variation
in fantasy in this population because
that's what's right in the process okay
it may be competitive it may not be so
if we take you know that line we look
for something observable that we can use
to settlement and I would say that the
best measure at the variance in fitness
okay and here the variance in Fitness is
just total notation rate times the
average selection coefficient which
actually turns out to be equal as a
result of Fisher's fundamental theorem
it equals the rate of decline in fitness
due to mutation Fisher showed very
elegantly that the increase in mean
fitness due to selection allele
frequencies is precisely equal to the
variance in Fitness which is a quantity
that must be limited by reproductive
capacity and in this mutation selection
balance model that must equal must be
offset by the decline in Fitness due to
mutation so that quantity even if you is
bigger than two if s is you know 1% or
so this will only be the order of a few
percent indeed there are few
measurements of the rate of decline in
the absence
selection immune Fitness there's Alex
condo shops famous middle-class
neighborhood experiment where he sort of
had the idea that you know you bring up
flies in a perfect world where they all
had two children and they all go to
school and so on whatever you remove
selection and then he showed that
selection sort of declined at some
rather slow difficult to measure rate at
any rate this this is clearly not a
strong constraint on how much selection
there could be we could under this view
have quite a bit more mutation we have
bigger genomes if we could manage it
okay so similar sort of issues with
substitution load we have apparently a
very strong general argument this is
really is a sort of generalization of a
halt dein argument which is true for
asexuals it's true with sexual
reproduction or multiplicative
businesses we just say that the
frequency of some type is equal to its
initial frequency times the ratio
between its fitness and the average
fitness in the population multiplied
over generations we take logs we find
that the log of the ratio between the
allele frequencies at the end of the
beginning is just equal to the sum of
this measure which is kind of measure of
the total log ratio between the maximum
reproductive capacity and the mean and
this again is limited by reproductive
capacity but again we can invade this
load we can see this rather easily if we
think of a sexual population we simply
think of how we would select most
efficiently for the good alleles we have
a whole lot of good alleles all very
rare we choose the best fraction theta
10% of the population and if we can
detect those alleles the best ones as
long as they're sufficiently rare will
all be in the top 10% top 10% so these
are the ills I'm imagining hundreds and
hundreds of alleles all at very low
frequency if we apply this perfect
truncation selection we'll be able to
increase each one by ratio 1 over theta
per generation
okay so we'll pretty quickly get all of
them to high frequency and in fact we
have almost a number getting to high
frequency once they're high frequency if
we don't have a combination we can't
bring them together and they'll be a
kind of traffic jam asexuality leads to
this problem of competition between
different favorable alleles but with
recombination we quickly bring them
together we quickly get to fixation and
this one caches is much more efficient
and some
to shion's or weekly selected alleles
can occur in very large numbers without
imposing
a very large variance in Fitness within
the population so if we take variance in
Fitness as our measure our constraint on
total reproductive variability within
the population we can see that we could
have a very large rate of substitution
lambda if s were sufficiently small if
we push the selection coefficient small
enough we find that selection becomes
ineffective when n s is of order 1 or
smaller and so we might expect roughly
that we would maximize the rate of
substitution if we had n s rather small
and I'll come back to this argument at
the end which I hope will be soon right
I expect you heard what we see
so finally drift load and we have here a
very beautiful result that his way back
to the 1930s so right I wouldn't say
like dorami predict he produced it the
the the formula emerged and it was later
justified rigorously used in diffusions
until the right simply could see somehow
that this formula a rather general
formula for the distribution of allele
frequencies provided we had linkage
equilibrium provided we have
recombination fast enough relative to
selection and it's very simple form
I'm just giving it in the simple case
with two alleles frequencies P I and Q I
lockers I mutation rates Mew iron new
iron opposite directions we have this
part which reflects the distribution
under mutation to direct the neutral
distribution and we have this part which
is encapsulating all of the effects of
selection and crucially this applies
whatever the pattern the relationship
between Fitness and genotype we can have
arbitrary epistasis this is one of the
very few results that is kind of
independent of the genotype phenotype
relationship I mean go further and say
if selection is acting on a set of
traits some very large number of traits
which are just related let's say they've
already distributed all or I would yet
need to make that assumption we're just
average over the allele frequencies -
conditional on those traits and we find
that we have now the distribution of the
mean and the variance or the mean and
the covariance of set of traits is again
a product or
the distribution they would have under
neutrality which I'll assume is rather
flat with this election the mean that
you know there aren't any strong genetic
constraints he would have had these
traits or these traits but then we have
this which is expressing the whole
effect of selection of those traits
selection on the mean and the variance
so if we focus on the mean of a single
trait just to get some sort of back then
no idea of what's going on and look at
the distribution of that trait around
some optimum at zero you find rather
easily that the mean Fitness is reduced
by one over foreign that's where the
simple drift low document came from but
again we can say well we don't really
believe that we can compare the ideal
organism which doesn't actually exist
with the average organism which will
deviate from the optimum at one of you
know many many trades so we say we're
interest in the variance in Fitness and
if you use the same argument together
the variance of fitness you find it's 1
over 18 squared and that's a much weaker
constraint you might sort of say well
we're prepared to have a variance of
fitness for one so that now the number
of traits we can maintain independently
nearer to dropped them is an order N
squared which is a much bigger number
than him I suppose to computer
scientists it's all polynomials so what
do we care we try to be more precise
simulation okay so finally a very
interesting result which is sort of
emerged rather recently which goes back
to the same kind of arguments I was
making rather roughly for substitution
mode and this is a people I must own in
at last sync pas which actually picks up
on a a very general result from
non-equilibrium thermodynamics buying us
in ski and I'm actually I don't know
what I've encouraged or depressed that
you know physicists are very clever
people took a long time to get to this
very general result which is you know I
think quite a dramatic generalization of
equilibrium thermodynamics so this is
what it looks like
if we take a population which starts at
some arbitrary distribution I should say
an ensemble of population starting some
arbitrary initial state we let it
evolved some other state under selection
mutation drift whatever
and we then calculate the expectation of
this quantity it's always equal to one
okay so that seems remarkably general
what are these two things well this Phi
is what's most ownin last a called
fitness flux and it's simply this sum of
the products of the selection
coefficient on an allele times the
change in that alleles frequency so if
you like it's analogous to work it's the
force times the response
it's the selection pressure times the
response to that selection and so this
actually has a rather tangible meaning
if we thought of a series of
substitutions at separately so going
from north to one this will be simply
the sum of the selection coefficients
over time but crucially fire can be
generally positive even if the
population in the long run is in a kind
of stationary state because we can have
a fixation of one allele under positive
selection selection can then change we
allowing changes in selection go back
and each of those changes if they are a
genuine response to selection will give
a positive fitness flux then H is simply
this measure of improbability we've seen
before in the camera holding argument
but it's now at the level of an ensemble
of populations and it's giving us the
basically the log of the relative
probability that the population will be
in its current state relative to the
neutral stationary reference state and
so it's a measure of in probability of
the final state and this is saying
something about the trade-off between
the strength of selection pushing the
population into a certain small region
of sequence space and that response that
compression of the probability
distribution into a smaller region so
it's kind of information measuring it
and this leads immediately to an
inequality which says that the fitness
flux times the population size provides
an upper bound to the increase in
information increase in probability if
you like so the difficulty is to
interpret what this means because
although I said the fitness flux it's
kind of in principle measurable it's not
clear as it provides a constraint well I
only have a sort of sketch of an
interpretation here which is to say well
let's suppose that the
frequency of rate of change is a
component due to selection spq plus
other stuff and say that this other
stuff will tend if anything to be either
neutral or to act in opposition to
selection this is goes back to Fisher's
idea that this component which he
identified as in fact the variance in
Fitness is counterbalanced by generally
negative components declines infants due
to other stuff which are random with
respect to adaptation and so we have the
idea that perhaps the total variance in
Fitness times population size provides a
bound on the total information so that's
kind of neat constraint it's actually an
extremely loose constraint because if
this is of order you know one per
generation if we had a really intense
process of selection we know the
population size in here so it's a much
much looser constraint than cameras
original result which was of order 2n
factor 2n different and so this says the
potentially sexual reproduction combined
with the right kind of gene interactions
could allow much faster accumulation of
information so summarize all that we
have population genetics which is kind
of tedious but we'll explain anything if
you tell through the inputs but of
course you don't know what the input is
we have quantitative genetics which come
up by magic gives a statistical and
rather accurate description of short
term evolution even the very very very
simple in predecessor model which is
consistent with in a bizarrely simple
additive model is remarkably accurate
and if we use this machinery we get
various kinds of load arguments which
appear to produce strong constraints if
we assume multiplicative effects of
creek nor gene interactions if genes
interact in the right way then these
constraints are drastically relaxed and
we have abundant possibilities of
selection to produce complex organisms
but this course leads to a question
which really Jonathan talked about
yesterday and which will probably come
up again which is why they should genes
interact in this way why should we
evolve to this sort of state in which we
can sustain a high mutation road etc etc
and these I think are quite difficult
questions so I shall stop the talk that